In our final video, we'll wrap up the course and discuss future considerations.
There are many ways to expand on the Datasmith capabilities we've already discussed, including
a number of other options when importing Datasmith, using Data Prep recipes, including using templates
like the Collab Viewer, which has architecture and automotive variations, and include robust
Datasmith capabilities already.
Some of what's coming up for Datasmith include more round-trip capabilities where we can
actually bring our data from Unreal Engine back to our DCC tools, and more capabilities
directly in Unreal Engine to reduce the need to go back to our DCC tools.
One final feature I'll show you, to give you a taste of what other Datasmith features are
in store, is Datasmith Runtime.
As mentioned, this also exists in the Collab Viewer template, and it is a way to load Datasmith
actors while in play mode, allowing for Datasmith files or GLTF files to be simply loaded into
memory without having to store them in your project.
Here in our empty scene, ensure Datasmith Runtime is enabled, and then here, I'll simply create
a Datasmith Runtime actor, which is actually referred to here as a Datasmith destination.
I'll leave that in the middle of my scene, and then I'll open up the level blueprint,
get a reference to our Datasmith Runtime actor, pull off of it, and go ahead and load file
from explorer.
Make sure we're coming off of begin play, and we could set a default path if we wanted
it to find a particular path automatically, but I can just compile this as is.
Go ahead and hit play.
It'll prompt me to load a Datasmith file, and I can go ahead and grab my old file,
cumulus exp with cone, and as our exposure gets set up, we can see we've got that Datasmith
file loaded directly into our scene.
And when I press stop, I'll find that because it was just loaded into memory, it's not
even here.
Thank you so much for following along this course.
My name again is Alex Coulomb, and I wish you well on your Unreal Engine journey.
Take care.